[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
another exciting episode of the careful
boys and today we have tim back in the
season
it's been so long dude last time i was
here y'all still had girls here yup
that's how long it's been and then we
went straight gay there was no careful
boys last time i was really there was no
such thing so you were you're not a part
of the attitude era then okay what was
that this is the attitude this is the
attitude
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
we're like
top five top five gay podcast yeah we're
pretty trending there in the in the
community we're progressive yep okay
which community we're pretty gay you you
know
okay
that's tight
yeah i'm we're with the fresh and fit
boys we're coming for their time
speaking of gay how's life man life is
like super gay super awesome yeah uh
it's it's uh it's busy man you know what
i'm saying blessed to be busy the the
the child is running and babbling like
saying a couple words here and there yo
how does she know one and a half wow
what's she saying what what her first
three different words um all three of us
on top of three words
top 15 sentences she said
uh okay well right off the bat the only
turtle i mean the only animals he always
recognizes is a turtle wow
turtle all the time no matter what it is
it's a turtle no no she knows it's oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah where do you guys
see that many turtles though uh you know
what teenage mutants teenage mutant
ninja turtles she has a little a toy
turtle
and i just random uh that's funny you
know randy so no dog
no giraffe just
turtle so dogs she sees and she does uh
you know
but she doesn't say dog and this is a
turtle she's like turtle soup
no she sees it she sees the turtle and
screams she goes kabanga and i'm like
whoa
really
[Laughter]
do you do you play her um
your favorite shows or the shows of
today
you mean like like toby maguire
spiderman no like for me like i play i
played him
the 90s ninja turtles
right i don't play him the [ __ ]
michael bay [ __ ] where like all the
turtles are all hood all of a sudden i i
play them in the 90s what the [ __ ]
chickens they're all dudes
not [ __ ] urban rappers and [ __ ]
michelangelo was the only urban one
there dog rafael no raphael he doesn't
watch movies
i was a new yorker for some reason
the only one
all the turtles were from new york i
think you guys are looking too much into
this he's italian
yeah raphael's italian duh
but they have california accents though
yeah cowabunga
so maybe the cartoon
maybe ours is the one that [ __ ] it up
then well which one do you play for her
i don't play none of the turtles [ __ ]
yeah this it's inappropriate what about
no just kidding i'm just kidding i'm
talking um we play a lot of blues clues
but the new one because he's asian so i
[ __ ] with filipino girl yeah yeah shout
out to josh
yeah the new the new host the new host
bro five years ago
yeah she loves [ __ ]
headlining it
he has a [ __ ] meet and greet and
everyone's like thank you for what
you're doing to the asian company yeah
dude i mean hey heavy real though
because there's episodes where like he
has his grandma on there and they're
like making like filipino like uh snacks
and [ __ ] yeah yeah does he call her lola
he calls her lola oh [ __ ] yeah dog so
that's tight man people but i watch i'm
like yeah
dude ryan's about to tear up right now
it's just a good moment for us
grandmother is a lot more syllables like
lola's like easy for everybody it should
just be like indoctrinated as like the
word everybody says lola yeah lolo i
think most people say granny i think no
one's like i'm fine grandmother
grandmother is here
do you play any like traditional thai
films for her no i couldn't even like
protect her protector okay she's all
like honey
this one's okay there's no carnival
but i do play her a lot of my videos
my music videos i just started playing
her my [ __ ] to just kind of show her
like oh look daddy daddy does things
yeah
she's all commenting
beat wasn't that hot yeah yeah yeah
she goes she goes on youtube she's like
mid
wow orange i play your videos she's like
sus
like chill my fingers on the point what
are you doing what is she picking up
right now that that you're like sketch
about like you're like wait where'd you
get that
um
i wouldn't say there's anything that i'm
like necessarily sketch about but she's
very she's getting to the age where she
likes to jump off of things you know
what i'm saying
so we need to kind of like always kind
of be aware like i had to leave town for
like two nights the other day to go
shoot some [ __ ] in new york and
and she is just so tired right now so i
get a text at like 9am she's like hey
vader fell off the couch but she's fine
had a little cry it's okay she's fine
i'm like oh god okay well all right cool
and then around like 2 p.m she's like
hey if it fell down a couple stairs
i was like god damn i need to get home
who who has the higher drop count right
now in terms of like dropping the baby
smells like cheetah look no
[Laughter]
no one's like officially dropped her but
for sure like sometimes we'll be like
where's veda and then we just hear like
like oh god where is she
she's just busy man um because i have
the higher drop count well tag is crazy
undefeated probably where she's like
zero she got like the mom like
you know yeah and then i have the dad
like okay
that's supposed to be dad's youtube
videos about that
those are all those are all fake those
are all oh man
cgi
or do you like you know have little
accidents with uh veda and then not text
chia
oh yeah uh no i'll keep her posted you
know what i'm saying uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um and then cheer comes home and just
like a [ __ ] big ass
i don't know that happened right
yeah what did you do
but uh nah man a lot of blues clues a
lot of [ __ ] uh like youtube just has
a playlist of like adorable songs um i
try to like work in like i'll put on
like
some like the usher uh tiny desk just to
kind of
see us
yeah just kind of like indoctrinate some
[ __ ] like og r b vibes into her
system you know what's something what's
something about like
fatherhood that you were like oh [ __ ] i
didn't [ __ ] expect this [ __ ]
like you thought man i got this and then
like you get veda and you're like oh
[ __ ] what is this i'll tell you this
i'll tell you this i didn't expect that
like because i always make jokes
whenever i got to go film or whatever
i'd be like ah man finally an excuse to
go out and turn up a little bit right
and i'll go to new york and be like all
right cool can't wait to get have a
couple drinks with the homies and then
i'll just be in the hotel looking at
like pictures of my child
how is she can we face time
like a separation anxiety yeah yeah
that's real huh no we had a pandemic
baby right so it's like i'm used to
being home every day with them so when
[ __ ] started picking up again i had to
leave i was like
oh is she gonna forget me
yeah so that's what i didn't really
expect right
um
did you ever watch that one clip it was
uh
bert kreicher with another stand-up
comedian
and it was a heartfelt moment and uh i
forgot
who the other comedian was but he was
pretty much saying like what sucks about
being a stand-up comedian
is that he's like he's checked into i
think 300 plus hotels a year
right and then so he's like talking
about how he has never been there for
his daughter's childhood and as he's
bawling like talking about like my i
wasn't there for like my daughter or
whatever
christian starts going
[Music]
like that right and then he's like
looking at him like what the [ __ ] he's
like this that's not funny and then he
goes i'm only laughing because it's true
and he starts volunteering
yeah i was like two different ways
yeah i was like that's [ __ ] crazy
like the stand-up comedian life yeah in
terms of balancing family because you
have to be on the road yeah yeah yeah
that's like a crazy constant grind yeah
yeah yeah thank god i you know i
internet for a living for the most part
because like you know that's kind of
cool
i did
that's pretty sweet um there was a uh
during towards the
maybe like sometime last year i had
auditioned for this movie that if i got
it i would have been in thailand for
like six months whoa and i was like oh
[ __ ] like what are we gonna do would you
just bring them with you probably for
that long yeah i would have like forced
chia like let's bring the baby to
thailand i got family out there they can
help whatever right um it would have
been difficult though uh but but luckily
oh is it because it's like the location
keeps moving everywhere yeah maybe just
because you know um i i would i just i
just like the baby to feel comfortable
you know what i'm saying and she likes
to feel comfortable so it was definitely
like ah and i got a call back for this
[ __ ] too like they they they told me
like yo you're on the list of potential
like they they're narrowing it down to
you and some other people but i didn't
get it and i was like low-key kind of
like how did you not get a thai thing
and it was a replacement
bro here's what's crazy dog you got thai
nikes dude it's that i do
who's his tie equivalent yeah here's the
thing it was that it was that ron howard
movie that came out about the uh 13 uh
soccer students oh yeah
and my part that i auditioned for i
didn't think i would even do well
because it was such a [ __ ] obscure
part it was a soccer ball
it was hot
it was ty winston from uh from [ __ ]
uh ty wilson wilson yeah yeah
just tim
tim's face they paddle shot the rest and
they paint a [ __ ] like the annoying
orange and [ __ ]
well sound like it's from paramount i
know right
but the the character was a thai dude
that grew up in america but he was from
the south so i had to do a [ __ ]
southern accent and [ __ ]
and i did not think i was gonna listen
nah man it was like
so here was one of the lines it was like
it was like general you can't drill here
this is sedimentary rock some [ __ ] like
that right sedimentary rock but i'm like
in my head i'm like i only do southern
accents when i'm [ __ ] around you know
what i'm like goddammit get off my lawn
that type of [ __ ] so you're higher
you shouldn't have it so i'm trying to
like tone it down i didn't think i'll
get i put on this is how [ __ ] i
didn't know what to do for this year
right they're like yeah he grew up in
the south so i'm like auditioning as
what i see as a [ __ ] southern person
so i took one of my flannel shirts and
cut the sleeves off
oh my god the hazard
straw coming out of your mouth
just way overboard
just to help sell it right you're on a
[ __ ] horse i didn't rolls up with
[ __ ] just overalls in a straw hat
like yeah that layer sedimentary rock
can't be drilling air partner
but uh
what needless to say my agent was like
hey they got you on the short list of
like they narrowed it down but i didn't
get it you know what i'm saying
um which was kind of hilarious because i
was like all right we don't have to
worry about going to thailand i'm going
to judge the guy who did get it by like
you better be real hard on that guy ask
for like a reimbursement for your
flannel though yeah what the [ __ ]
reparations for the sleeves bro
oh [ __ ] i think i even put on a flannel
over like it might have been like a
stone cold steve austin show oh man
smash some beers
what they were looking for is someone
from southern thailand
i misread it wait so there was something
still talking like southern american
thai guy in that group
he was perfect like southern california
that's all we need i know so this
character apparently was a real
character it was a guy that
grew up in the south but he was thai and
he would go to thailand for this in the
summers to he was like a [ __ ] rock
brain expert whatever the [ __ ] his
character was i don't even know the
geologist sure
i liked him
dude
but yeah man that was it you know um and
then that was your role and then you're
gonna get it and i i i but i didn't get
it and i was and i was glad but do you
know who replaced you i haven't watched
it it's out though i heard it's good oh
it's out yeah yeah i think it's on
a streamer
it could have been great i think i think
tv johnny would have been a great
replacement
johnny
[ __ ] johnny daniels
dude
oh dude that guy's everywhere yeah
she's very tight passing
in that situation of that story yeah
just tv johnny i don't know where with
the grills
that's really southern dude i know this
still rocks like a middle part oh yeah
it's coming back so it's ken
that's true what about your uh mtv
schedule like for deliciousness and all
that deliciousness is lit because they
they really worked around all our
schedules and we knock out like three
episodes a day oh yeah yeah oh but they
were telling me ridiculous in the
schedule they do six episodes a day whoa
bang that [ __ ] out bro
he's a [ __ ] machine they knock it out
make mad money
deliciousness it was like
it was like every other day for like two
weeks and then we just knocked out and
you shoot in l.a yeah so it's easy to
balance your family life around it yeah
it's super easy so you shot a whole
season in like two weeks yeah like 20
episodes wow 30 hours
yeah good i tricked out to see you just
riffing with tiffany amber thiessen i
know
what is this dude that's crazy it was
like man not gonna lie i was high key
like fangirling on stage you know first
day especially i'm like looking like oh
my god she still looks bald can i look
up she does yeah
and then after the first day she was
like she was really like she was really
she found me funny you know what i'm
saying so after we filmed she's like hey
oh my god i'm a fan now you're so funny
she's like you're so cute you're so
funny i was like
oh my god i was like i was like time out
so
kelly kapowski
but now she's dope she's super sweet did
she know that you grew up watching her
yeah of course oh did she know that you
also grew up being knocked off um look i
think she can assume that you know
uh but it was just it was just really
humbling to to be on the stage because
it's like i feel like everyone on that
stage i'm in that show with i like grew
up watching in different just parts of
my life you know what i'm saying like
angela from the office and then kale so
it was kind of like and i'm up there i'm
like ah man what about the rubbing off
thing though um yeah yeah yeah you think
girls really like fully assumed that you
think they could like walk into a room
if they knew that they were a specific
character at a certain era where there
was like less access and you're just
like they walk into this room they're
like maybe not maybe definitely yes well
when we had mia khalifa here she said
she could be in the supermarket and she
just can go oh okay he walked off to me
oh that way he looked at me he out he
whacked off to me it's the eyebrows that
go up she could just sense it yeah i
mean she does a different genre of
content
people mostly seriously called it a
genre she wasn't on must-see tv
it depends on who you talk to it's a
different kind of medium you know see
tv
okay back to less shallow water so who
else was on this uh so speaking of super
shallow just see
um
my favorite genre of porn is probably uh
um no wait wait what were you asking
no i wasn't sure if we're gonna joke no
no i like it now oh sure [ __ ] it uh well
i don't really have a specific genre i
kind of like i'm very uh my taste of
porn is like everywhere you feel me like
one night it's like oh you know what
uh maybe i'll watch some japanese [ __ ]
where everything's pixelated and then
another night i'm like you like
frustration huh
you know what no here's the thing
i am one of my favorite draws of the
japanese porn and the reason why i
overlook the pixelation is because i
just like the uh the noise they make oh
you actually like the noise i dig it
it's like very crying huh i uh you know
i look it depends on each culture it
depends on my mood uh sometimes you can
just play it and like listen to it in
your headphones and jackoff i don't i
don't mind ripped away files
background while i'm washing dishes
washing dishes and jerking off just
listening like it's in a podcast sounds
like cats [ __ ]
but sometimes japanese sometimes i'll go
for some bbw action uh it all depends
yeah you don't watch is there any thai
porn that you like tuck tuck patrol have
you heard of tucked on patrol
it's an up-and-coming one that's stevie
weeby's top three favorite really it's a
real thing patrol yeah
[Laughter]
no i think they pick up girls in the
tuck tuck and then they go somewhere
interesting oh yeah it's actual its own
site tuxpatrol.com they got a dot com
it's a sponsor for the show actually oh
well that looks great yeah uh it says
nobody rides for free
[Laughter]
no ty [ __ ] left behind sign up
now thai [ __ ] left behind genuine thai
porn since 2020 uh 2012 we've been
cruising the world famous streets of
thailand for hot thai [ __ ] our talk
talking control sail like that video
features real-time sex [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] by real tourists dude i want to
be a copywriter for [ __ ] porn
it's like this is so tantalizing
that's like such a well-written intro no
thai [ __ ] left behind like damn dude
on some of these they look great they
got testimonial sections oh wow
honest pornography five stars
what does angela from new york say about
it
uh patrol continues to keep it real and
is worth checking out rabbits reviews
it's worth checking out real
joined this site and haven't left in
three years gilgamesh 1975. gilgamesh
damn he's been around for millions of
years of this stuff yeah have you guys
ever read the comments
on like porn sites like because you know
how like a lot of those uh videos if you
click boys in the comments there's
actually comments like youtube on every
single one acting like you don't know
yeah uh
no i've seen the comments before i out
of curio like right after you nut and
you just gotta scroll
yeah it's really weird it'll be like
what's her who's her name what's her
name or whatever or like they'll be like
they'll be like oh my god if i could
only just bust in her all the time i
would lick her [ __ ] after she pisses or
like crazy [ __ ]
yeah
what else do they say
yeah give her something
it is weird yeah only one time on that
same on the same lane at a homie that
like you know i hooked up with this girl
and the homie was like man she's so bomb
let me know next time you smash i'll
suck your dick
[Laughter]
it was a joke
dude don't tell him i said
that's so long
i forgot who it was but i was watching
this thing and then they're talking
about beyonce and then someone said that
i will [ __ ] suck the fart out of her
ass do you guys remember that [ __ ]
not like you could
get one celebrity name in that yeah you
know you could switch that out i've
heard that said before about like
different people yeah people probably
said about you too yeah that's it that's
a new one for me
is it yeah it's insane you're just old
bro that is that is a good bumper
sticker it feels like the right place to
have it
on the on the bumper
[Music]
hmm
[Music]